[Music]
foreign
's most closely contested election in
decades election observers said the
voter turnout was high president's
reject is facing his toughest electoral
challenge in 20 years most of the
opposition United to back Kamal kalish
darulu and the government's response to
devastating earthquakes in February and
a struggling economy are seen as top
voter concerns now at a moment we're
going to be going live to our
correspondence ashram Sami zaidan is in
Istanbul but first Russell Cedar begins
our coverage
many consider this election to be
turkey's most significant in recent
history
erdogan voted in Istanbul where he began
his political career
he has reshaped turkey over the last two
decades his supporters believe he has
made the country more powerful and
prosperous
we want everyone to vote because the
independence and future of the country
is at stake we came here to vote for the
stability and the growth of our country
to continue
stability and continuity have been
keywords throughout erdogan's election
campaign
he is now prompting a more assertive
turkey in the international Arena
he ended his campaign by visiting Aya
Sofia Istanbul's famous mosque and
historic cultural site to appeal his
conservative base
[Applause]
however after more than two decades in
power he now faces his most difficult
challenge
six opposition parties have joined
forces for this presidential and
parliamentary elections with opposition
leader Kamal kharistarolo chosen as
their Unity candidate
his supporters are growing more
confident that he will be turkey as next
president
our power has declined at the at the
time the rule of law has vanished
justice has vanished I want my country
to become better in terms of Justice the
rule of law and living conditions
election campaign his main messages were
change and whole promises are more
inclusive democracy at home and stronger
ties with the West
campaign by visiting anat Kabir the
Muslim or the founder of the Turkish
Republic Mustafa Kemal attitude that is
regarded as a symbol of secularism and
republicanism in the country
along with the symbolic Maneuvers many
in Turkey believe the economy will be
the most important factor determining
the election outcome people are facing
rocketing prices as the country has one
of the highest inflation rates in the
world that has been exacerbated by the
two earthquakes in February to an
outright a candidate must get more than
half of the world If no candidate get at
least 50 plus one would in the first
round the presidential election will be
decided in a second round on May 28th
between the two candidates who received
the most walls Ankara
okay let's cross the Sami zidane who's
in Istanbul for Sammy so the polls have
closed what happens next when are we
going to know the results
[Music]
right you're joining us uh Rob amid the
call to prayer amid strong calls for
people to come out and vote and to
answer your question what happens next
well 5 p.m local which is just a few
minutes ago we cross 5 PM local is when
polls were slated too close and in fact
now as we go through I'm getting word
from our team we've had official
confirmation that those polls have now
officially closed the polls have
officially closed so there was some
thought that maybe it might there might
be a delay in beginning the vote
counting because some long lines were
seen at some polling stations but it
seems we're beyond that point
now they start counting those votes now
we are not allowed to talk about results
until the cutoff time according to the
rules which is 7 PM local that's 1600
GMT official results Rob will come out
in three days which yes I know what
you're thinking that feels like a
lifetime in a situation like this where
a nation is on knife edge wanting to
know where these crucial elections
presidential parliamentary elections are
taking a nation that is vital in global
Affairs but the good news is as of 7 PM
local we can start to talk about some of
the unofficial results that will start
coming in that will give us a strong
indication of who's winning and who's
losing but for now got a setback fasten
that seat belt and hold your breath Rob
so I mean just as you've been talking to
us we've been looking at some live
pictures from at least from one of the
the polling stations that I think is in
Istanbul it does look as though what I
can see from the agency feeds here they
are beginning to total up at least the
papers that they have in front of them
what is going to be key in all of this
and I know you've been talking about
this since the polls opened is the
number of people who actually went out
to vote do we have any indication of
what the turnout has been like
yes absolutely we've had some indication
from our teams which are right across
this country watching these polling
stations not only in the major cities Al
Jazeera is also in some of those rural
heartlands where let's not forget people
were hit but millions of people were hit
by those devastating earthquakes and the
constant message the consistent message
we're getting back from our teams is
that there does seem to be a good
turnout turnout's been strong
particularly here in Istanbul and that's
important although this is not of course
the political capital of the country but
this is the economic the cultural heart
of turkia it is the country's most
populous city a fifth of the population
around a fifth of the population lives
here and by some measures even the
biggest city in Europe depending on how
you calculate that so what happens here
and how much of a turnout is being
watched very carefully this is what I
can tell you
every indication people have been
absolutely energized in Istanbul over
this election we've seen scenes not only
the strong turnout sadly in some cases
in different parts of this country three
cases of people having heart attacks a
polling supervisor and two voters having
heart attacks because of the the almost
palpable excitement the tension that has
gripped this country I mean I can tell
you part of my childhood was in turkia
I've seen elections before it's hard to
remember a time in Turkish political
history when things have been this tense
when people have been this fired up and
energized the good news is here we are
polls have closed no major reports of
any major security incident so far no
major major reports of any claims of
irregularities at polling stations so
far Rob Sammy thank you very much indeed
Sami zidan bringing us up to date from
Istanbul
who's in the Turkish Capital anchor so
Sami was describing Istanbul as the
economic and cultural Hub of the country
you're in the political Center of uh of
turkey what does a high turnout mean for
reject erdogan
it is going to be a crucial moment for
him for his party the ACT party and for
his legacy I mean it has been a busy day
here they've been long lines at most of
the polling stations this has been a
decisive moment since the start of the
election campaign you have
two main candidates offering two
different Visions about how to move
forward and I think it's because of that
that sadly you have this fear that this
could be an historic moment for turkey
and this explains at the very high
turnout people predict this could be one
of the highest turnouts over the last
few years what does it mean for
president erdogan he's looking forward
to see people vindicate his legacy he
said that he has been doing everything
it took him to preside over what he has
always described as an unprecedented
economic boom he said that he has built
infrastructure across the country from
scratch he said that he has introduced
introduced major political reforms but
at the same time he said that he
considers all the accusations leveled
against him by the opposition by and by
the West that's for example
this is someone who has been making
friends with autocrats it has been
eroding democracy in his country as
politically motivated he's looking
forward to see people vote for him in
huge numbers although people suggest
that this could perhaps be a tight
election but you know this is someone
who has paraded the political stage in
Istanbul in the 90s and nationally when
he established his party and when he
wanted actions in 2002 and globally when
he became a key political player he does
understand that when you are in power
for 20 years it will be extremely
delicate to convince people time and
again to vote for you in huge numbers
this explains why you're getting all
this sense of excitement and anxiety
about what happens in the upcoming hours
imagine just we've just been looking at
some pictures of Elizabeth voting in
Istanbul and interestingly immediately
afterwards I understand that he traveled
to Ankara Where You Are which is not
something that that normally happens I
want to ask you about what however is
happening in the opposition Camp the the
opposition that is United to backlu
foreign
did understand from the beginning that
there is absolutely no way that can win
the election if they don't come together
and it was because of people like Kamal
kilistador the leader of the main
opposition party CHP who has managed to
stitch together this Coalition with six
political parties known as the nation
Alliance or the table of six
there are
to disagree over huge issues but now
they decided that it was about time for
them to come together and win the
election if they win that will
considerate this stance that will bring
them together for the future if they
lose the Coalition could disintegrate
and this is why they are adamant on the
need to win tonight they say that the
reason why they think they will be
winning this election is because they
say they have been offering the Turkish
people a new vision for the future a
vision they say is going to be based on
strengthening
democracy in the country democracy which
they say has been eroded under aquapatia
and president two
in particular an economist say that this
is going to be an opportunity for him to
fix the economy to invite
foreign investors to come into the
country and to create a robust economy
in the country so we have to wait and
see what will be the choice of the
people in the upcoming hours
are talking to us from the Turkish
capital Ankara Hashem thank you